i'm here with the amazing whoopi
goldberg let's get back into it
now
yes one thing yes
you know
i have definitely feel like i've dug my
heels and about and i'm not sure lately
if i should be so fundamental about it
is i have sworn off dating even though i
date occasionally but i've sworn off
relationships
where are you at with relationships i
think they're great for other people
this is exactly what i've been thinking
is that they're not
for me not right now it's not for listen
for many many years i thought i've got
to get this right
and then i realized one day i don't got
to get this right
i got this right for me why do i need
you to come into my bathroom and
irritate me
i
nothing makes me angrier than the double
sink movement i'm like i don't want a
double sink
i want a single sink
and also if you're a single what do you
do with that second seat it does it
doesn't
work i can tell you what you can do what
rinse out your underwear
rinse it out
bring it out and snap it
now
get the hanger line dry it put it right
in there okay you can do all kinds of
stuff with a double sign so you said
not now
is there an openness to a later do i
need to be open to later because i think
i am are you do you want a relationship
no i can sit on your face not right now
i i heard a story where you were dating
like a younger man that's also like a
big time yeah
[Applause]
i'm on a dating app sometimes i'll swing
swipe by and it's like this 35 year old
guy will run by i'm 46 and i'm like i
already have two children i don't need
another
and so then i'm like well that's not
gonna work and then i'm like oh i
wouldn't want someone judging me on my
age age doesn't really represent people
but i think i would love to be with
someone
who
they cannot it cannot be five years you
cannot make the distance five years you
think so
you you can't because if they're five
years younger than you there's a whole
section of time that's gone
that makes it difficult i i once had a a
partner
who said to me once
i did not know paul mccartney had
another band other than wings
then wings
yeah it was young
and i said um
so you don't know much about the beatles
this is a while ago you don't know about
the beatles
and then he said it
who are the beatles oh my god
and that's that's too young
yeah yeah i yeah
yeah i do i do i you know what it's nice
to know that i would just like to be
with someone my own age or older like i
just want to keep moving forward if
you're going to do a hit and run you can
have somebody younger
i just
because
let us not forget you know sometimes you
don't want an entire relationship yeah
uh-huh you just need a little
well
a little i love talking to you about
this i really really truly do
tell me why the holidays are so
important to you and how this collection
came about because i'm a looking and i'm
a lichen i want some of this schwag i
want to bring it for the holidays whoopi
how is it done tell me how we do the
holidays and where we can get this
amazing beautiful i wanted to say joyful
and then i'm literally looking at it joy
lux
joy lou
um
and b-y-o-n
[Applause]
is it french
these are all the languages i could fit
on the sweater so
i love crazy sweaters and i loved all of
the sweaters i saw other people wear and
i thought i would draw some and i'm a
terrible artist but i draw my squiggles
and then i hand it to the people and
they go is this what you mean and then
they hand me a visual of what i'm
thinking i say yes and so this is the
fourth or fifth year sixth year maybe
sixth year that we've done these and and
i like them because they make me happy
and i hope they make up they are so
happy
and if you go to our website on the
drewberrymart show.com we will link you
to buy all this schwag i'm going to be
head to toe
with my daughters
and in all of this and my daughter now
is calling santa claus santi c
well yeah you know she knows they talk
she's like i know we're lighting the
menorah mom but like santi c is also we
got to do the tree i'm like let's fall
about the holiday it's all about the
holiday and about the kids we got to
make this work
for the kids you know got to make it
work for the kids
so we have the messaging the mentality
and the outfits to crush it this holiday
season thank you
i hope so and i can't wait to know you
the rest of my life ditto and i love you
so much
and make sure you go to the dreamweaver
show.com we will link you to buy
whoopi's incredible sweaters and they're
also available at nordstrom the whole
collection oh good and we'll be right
back
[Music]